when i was a kid i used to read books
like this all the time actually
i still read books like this in this
novel by arthur c clarke the world has
created colonies on in other parts of
the solar system including
the moon titan surrounding saturn the
time of troubles is over
war and poverty are dead key words here
are war and poverty are dead
today i want to discuss a theme science
fiction
and fantasy especially are our genres
that really reflect the world
we live in when i was a kid and i loved
reading
isaac asimov and ray bradbury and arthcy
clark writers who worked in the
50s 60s reading their books filled me
with a kind
of um excitement about the future right
of course there were there were problems
and issues but
primarily they were new problems i think
a lot of these boomer writers of the 50s
and 60s were writing
with this idea that okay our problems of
today are going to be gone
in a number of years it's inevitable
we're not going to have
these unjust systems of course they
don't really name
capitalism as being the problem it's
just war and poverty are gone they've
been solved by
collective you know look at star trek i
mean star trek is a perfect example of
this
it's basically like a communist utopia
now they are sending peaceful missions
out into the universe just to explore
a lot of science fiction in that time
was like this while they may be
pessimistic about certain things
artificial intelligence might be a
problem in the future you know our
current problems
will be solved by then they must be they
have to be to me
this is such a boomer mindset
and i don't mean that in a bad way this
mindset really reflects the kind
of eternal prosperity and eternal
progress
i guess you could call that a modernist
viewpoint the sense that progress is
inevitable it's going to come
that's kind of why i still like to read
books like these today because
you don't find a lot of fiction a lot of
science fiction with that kind of
thinking
today and i guess we're going to go back
eternally to
frederick jameson's it's easier to
imagine and into the world
than into capitalism which brings us to
the genre
of dystopian fiction i'm talking about
huge
mass appeal of the dystopian genre in
like
the 2010s you got maze runner you got
hunger games
you got the spider wars i don't know
dystopian fiction as a young adult genre
is
so weird to me like when you actually
look at it objectively like okay
all these young pre-teens and teenagers
and kids
are becoming obsessed with this genre
that is all about
a future in which everything is dog [ __ ]
there is absolutely no hope
it's this fundamental sense that yeah
the world
is slipping away there's not going to be
a solution these science fiction books
of the past
while not always proposing a
way to get to this utopian ideal
there is a sense that okay progress will
come today that sense of progress
where is it and i don't blame people for
not having that optimistic view
there's a reason you don't see books
like this written anymore
i mean it's corny as hell 2 2276
will there be an america probably not
which brings me to my next point
a bit of a standing up on a soapbox for
a second but
hear me out i think that writers
fantasies speculative fiction writers
science fiction writers that it is
possibly in
the world's benefit to speculate about
worlds that aren't [ __ ] okay
i truly believe that to get to a stage
beyond
capitalism we have to imagine that it
can be in
so many different ways that's the
freedom of the genre we can speculate
about how we will get to these points
i don't think you can force this type of
optimism and i don't think that we need
to be needlessly sappy
just speculating about how would we get
to this stage
is important which basically the science
fiction writer ken stanley robinson
discusses um there's a wonderful jacobin
article or interview with kim stanley
robinson where he discusses his new book
the ministry
for the future in which he looks at
every
step if every country came together and
actually
uh implemented the paris climate of
course it's an interesting
idea and it's interesting to see a
writer imagine these things
trying to picture these things is
important we can only have so much
despair there's there's only so much we
can do
with this you know the dystopian genre
is
there's nothing inherently detrimental i
just think it's
reflective of the situation of late
capitalism
stagnation and decline in people's
standard of living and it's important to
recognize how bad it is
and to reflect that in our fiction in
our media i think it's also important to
look towards the possibilities of the
future and that's why i love reading
stuff like this and anyways thanks for
watching
and i hope you all are are enjoying life
bye bye